i was hoping maybe we could go down this
list a little bit
and get sure and get your perception of
what they are
and what promise they hold for the
future sure
does that work okay so yeah okay so if
you can define
ethereum to the viewers right now what
is that and why is it important
so for me it's like i said before it's
hard to define it exactly how bitcoin is
like bitcoin as it stands today for the
last couple of years is a store of value
that's it like people
aren't building anything on top of it
per se well they are trying to but
hasn't taken hold for me i think
ethereum
people are trying to paint it as uh it's
it's everything type of thing when it's
everything it's nothing type of deal
right so it's very hard to sell the
narrative when it's everything but for
me i would
i heard people say that it's like the
oil and gas of
the internet economy is that what it is
yeah
but that narrative digital
to sell you know people like the reason
why store value works there's two
functions to that right so number one
people automatically know what a store
value means and when you say digital
gold
right you're building off of a heuristic
of understanding the value of gold
so your actual processing bandwidth to
understand the value proposition and
what bitcoin is
takes this but second as opposed to
saying well ethereum is the old what's
beyond oil ethereum is also collateral
acid on d5
there's billions of dollars locked you
need eath as well
for gas so that's the oil you also need
ether other computational aspects so
it's like a trifecta all these different
types of properties
that eat represents for me at least
today
uh ethan's the biggest playground
for experimentations and developers and
new economic
protocols being developed in the web3
space
got it
you